hey guys this is the founder tiara and
I'm David Griffin your resident comic
book in video game guru and this is our
review of Game of Thrones season 4
episode 5 the midway point I've already
halfway there
yeah the first of his name Tommen gets
you knows a little time to shine there
it gets his crown put on his head he's a
big man yeah a man mana chars
I really like this episode I thought
there was a lot of great moments in it
let's start it with King's Landing you
know yeah Tommen gets crowned as king
and and we got to see that scene what
was interesting is is Cersei coming into
Margaery like kind of like trying to be
nice yeah we know she has ulterior
motives we get that from Cersei
sometimes we got it if we remember back
to season 1 with Catelyn there was a
really nice moment when Catelyn was
sitting in the you know brands
bedchamber as he was recovering from you
know getting pushed out of a window and
you know she kind of opened up about her
child you know that died you know I
think it was actually probably the one
legitimate child she was gonna have with
Robert when he was alive and like every
now and then she'll open up we think
like wait is she kind of trying to be
nice or is she like I feel like sometime
we got to see it twice in this episode
but of course as we know we're gonna
talk get to get to get to a Prince
Oberyn later there's always an ulterior
motive with her so she can't open up
it's always something yeah but I think I
haven't read the books but from what
people tell me like the TV series
version there she's much more there's
much more sympathy for her because oh
definitely because she's more
multi-dimensional yeah I can't stand her
in the books okay cuz in the TV series
it's like yes she is like all these bad
things that people say writer but
there's more to her care she's just that
I mean a hadees' is doing such a great
job every week knocking out of the park
she's so good like she's she makes her
character fun to watch but when you're
reading her in book form it's kind of
like yeah that's not that interesting
and then one Aria Cersei to this week it
seems like if she trying to like play
the game more by like you know
pretending to be nice to be like now
she's kind of talking with her father
Tywin and kind of say no you're right
it's about the legacy and like I'll do
what it takes and blah blah go ahead you
can Victorian for me while you're at it
though you know like it and then it
would over and same thing it's like you
wonder you know first of all that scene
was kind of cool cuz and again I'm not
thinking about the book so I'm just
thinking of just hypothetical
because you know Benioff and Weiss may
go away from the book say they've said
publicly they may do something different
so it almost seemed when she was talking
to Prince Oberyn like she was either
because he is on the the council or I
guess the judges you know for the trial
trying to like be like hey you know you
and I are like you know like I lost a
son you lost your sister you and I are
like but the same time I almost was
waiting for her to like tell like maybe
offer like a proposal like marriage you
know what I mean like maybe we could
like hook up you know and like build an
alliance you're very powerful and strong
I'm very powerful in the straw goes it
really it was a great conversation like
it could go a lot of different ways with
that yeah and she's also talking about
the love she has for her dog right who
is an indoor nerd right yeah and with
the president and all that right yes or
say I don't know she still thinks Tyrion
did it and I still think deep down she
knows that Tyrion didn't right and then
just my guess is like I don't I think
she knows it but she doesn't care and
she hates Tyrion just she wants some
reason just to get him out of her life
forever and this is the one good way
because even you could tell his dad
isn't even that he's not like a vengeful
guy against hearing he's just like look
I'm a judge I can't talk about the trial
outside of the you know the courtroom so
that's gonna be interesting
okay yeah and then we also have Petyr
Baelish you know taking Sansa to the
Vale and I guess they you know have to
use this alternate name for her so no
one knows it's once's there there was a
big reveal in this episode or in that in
the scene with with Petyr Baelish see
who the puppet master is yeah cuz we now
we find out that he convinces Lysa to
poison Jon Arryn cuz the whole time
we're thinking she had sent that message
to to her sister Catelyn and so we're
thinking oh it's the Lannisters it's the
land right right no actually Petyr
Baelish is you know pulling something
this is from back in the day because I
mean this is like first episodes we
never even got to see Jon Arryn except
for you know Dennis laughs I know so now
we know who was pulling the strings
before Ned even thought about going to
King's Landing so I mean Petyr baelish's
he's you know he's he's crazy when I
love to see and of course you see the
crazy kid you know you know Robin Robin
her son is just I want to see that Ben
fly you know this is kind of a crazy kid
but then I love the moment between
Liza Lysa and Sansa that was a great
moment when they were you know having
some
Hertz and she's like you know squeezing
their hands and basically she's jealous
of her because we do know that
Littlefinger loved Catelyn Stark like
that's who he wanted to be with like
that's what he fought you know even
fought for her at one point in his life
and you know Sansa resembles her she has
the hair she's very pretty you know and
that's why it's like why are you around
like if you see did you have any
pregnant are you pregnant so that was
that was a really good scene well again
Lysa is off-the-wall crazy she's crazy
same with Reddy's son where Petyr
Baelish she's not crazy he's just evil
yeah he's very small smart but he's evil
cuz even you can see like in their kiss
and he wasn't he was kind of like yeah
and she was like going crazy yeah it was
good I mean yeah she said she was gonna
be heard from all over the Vale so
creepy
it was nice going back to the build I
loved the the special effects the CG let
me know we talked about this Michelle
Maclaren was one of my favorite TV
directors has worked on you know x-files
and Breaking Bad and of course Game of
Thrones - did a great job shooting this
episode it was really really spectacular
yeah the Scimitar faith I mean the
Scimitar being so it's fantastic but
this one I noticed it more especially
with the production value of all the
stuff like yeah we you know we talk
let's talk about Daenerys yeah yeah even
it's a short scene but they're in this
one room and it's like a different style
than that we've seen before right right
and and we've learned about how she's
not gonna be leaving no all right to go
to Westeros even though it might be the
most opportunity time could I'll do all
that are wanting to be like Wednesday
only gonna get involved when is she
gonna actually get going well it looks
like she said she wants to rule so she
needs to look after the places that
she's conquered and it is it is kind of
freshman even from a book reading
standpoint you know let's say like what
I'm not talking about the future was
talking about currently right now while
you're reading it's like you do want her
to go to Westeros and kind of you know
meet the people over there and get
things going and cuz especially like
when she almost seems so isolated over
there you know and like I mean you know
as a non Booker to you what do you think
about her over there is is that like
interest you that's her story sometimes
seem too distant or not so much so
distance but they do slow it down
sometime
season two you know and she was kind of
walking the Red Waste right yeah that
was a lot of snow down there it picked
up in season three and then this it's
really been picking up in season four
yeah but now we kind of gotten to
another standstill because she needs to
go lip real iterate really replaces that
one more time
homer time and I understand the
reasoning because she wants like her
word to matter and yeah like she doesn't
want to be like okay oh I free these
people but then I leave and then you
know all the bad [ __ ] happens again my
you know another you know other masters
come in or you know other kings and all
that stuff so I think she needs that she
wants to assert her power great so it
kind of makes sense but in the story
wise it's like okay well now she's gonna
go do that right who knows when she's
gonna actually cross the Narrow Sea
right and I really like the conversation
the beginning between sir Barristan and
Jorah I like the strategizing like you
know well with 8,000 unsullied in two
thousand like could we and they're like
well you know jurors not so sure but
then he's like well you know if we
surprised in bearson's like we surprise
him get in there you know they don't see
us coming maybe we could do it but then
I did like Jorah was like look eight
thousand ten thousand men it's not
enough to conquer all of Saul the seven
kingdoms you know and yeah it's only
enough to possibly take over King's
Landing if he takes Kings Lane that
doesn't mean you you have West right now
I always love that you're always jabs
her cuz do things like you know they'll
you know they'll bear since it's like
bill don't want to rally to her and all
that and they're like no they're gonna
houses are gonna rally behind this side
they think is gonna win which is they
always do they don't see these Kings as
saviors like Bennis see this one good
food they want to feel safe and that's a
also what position who decide with will
get them the better position right
mm-hmm right and in there we've been
making those money exactly that's why
you had Roose Bolton and Walter Frey
right jump to landslide even though they
were supposed to be loyal to the Starks
right and then I guess I want to go on
just to talk about I guess I'm curious
to hear if you phone still gonna jump
back to King's Landing real quick and
what's up with the whole discussion with
Tywin and Cersei about the iron bank oh
you see if that interests you at all
because they're gonna make is something
you always hear alluded to it's just you
know it's it's the bank man and you
don't pay your debts they come after you
but it is interesting
actually here the economics it's nice
because it is nice to see that these
kingdoms just don't flourish on nothing
you know he talks about even though I
guess it's kind of boring economics but
I mean you know there's been no gold
mined and a long time there's no grams
there's no ounces there's no tons
there's nothing we've had to borrow
that's well that's where the Lannisters
money is being tired from and I guess
that has stopped not just now but even
Tyler seems intimidated by this iron Bay
like he talked to searched look these
people are serious like you don't mess
with these people they'll always be
there like even if we attack them or did
something like they're always gonna be
there so like I think that was kind of
cheating to bring in the iron bank in
the whole conversation and you know we
know that Stannis and Davos were talking
about that yeah remember Devin wrote
some letters iron brain you understand
this name and and I'm sure that plays in
next episode or the rest of the season I
guess what we need to see is someone who
hasn't read the book I need we need to
see how dangerous this iron bank but I'm
just talking about doesn't mean yeah I
think I didn't say anything you have to
see like someone who doesn't pay their
debts and like right be like how
brutally right things happen to them
right torture murder something something
back cuz you've got to have that fear
yeah yeah because if even Tywin is
afraid of yeah yeah then they obviously
are very dangerous right yeah so I mean
I think that's gonna mean so hopefully
we get some more that I mean it's crazy
it's already halfway there but in that I
guess you can go with maybe talk we're
talking about our favorite duo and all
well there's two duo's now yes they look
start with a more powerful one first are
you around yeah there's like a whole
show on yeah they're great they shed
their own spin-off show they're awesome
I love and he's just naming all the
names like what you're gonna mention
every single person he's like alright go
ahead and finish then she says the Hound
you know is one of the people that she
wants to kill he's got some calls on OSU
stuff yeah she's like she's got way more
bravery than most of the people in there
and I love the the the fight scene and
like him kind of teaching her because
which energy does she carries a small
weapon yeah
Prince Oberyn it seems like the eastern
people and then Dorne like they carry
they don't carry big massive giant
swords and you know he's like you need
you need big armor and big source Prince
Albert doesn't fight like that Bravo so
you know the hoser her teacher's name
the water dancer yeah yeah I think he
wore light like they don't wear heavy
armor they dance they're kind of flashy
a little different type of fighting
she doesn't present perfected it yet so
she doesn't know how to use it against
the hound but what's interesting to see
him like teacher like no you need a big
sword strong but also she's not even
she's tiny - yeah hounds her age and her
size she doesn't have any strength right
not with that little weapon but you know
maybe if she goes olders right holds
like maybe a lighter sword yeah that
could pierce the armor but you know not
with that
no that would need a needle yeah do you
okay I do that so that's I always enjoy
seeing them and so like the other duo
were talking about Brienne and pod yeah
they're hilarious because you know it's
like Podrick even though he's like
technically a squire he really hasn't
done any of the squire like stuff you
know he was doing it for Tyrion even
admit he just pours wine babe exactly
but he did gain more respect because he
told Brienne the story of how he saved
Tyrians life and I think that was cool
and how hilarious though was a scene
when he's writing the whole trying to
write it well like all over the right
yeah I love the shot cuz it cuts to this
wide shot well you see the shadows yeah
you just see it Podrick just try right
the horse and I like to see like what he
started what he burns a rabbit mm-hmm so
you never cook rabbit before he's just
like no he's like whoo BAE is like well
The Cook's did all the cooking I didn't
to do it so I mean it was just great
seeing them and she was nice and let
them you know do something useful like
you know get her armor off so I mean
that's a nice little relation I like
being such a good character I miss
Brienne and Jaime together I'd rather
have Brienne and Jaime on a road trip
together again even though we already
had that but Podrick a great character
too and he's gonna get a lot to do and
then we have finally Craster's keep
yeah a lot of stuff went down what I
thought might happen didn't happen okay
let me not I'm from the books I mean we
thought it would be an eventual what I
meant is an eventual meeting between
Johnny the reunions are between John and
brand then I was like it didn't happen
we didn't see the reunion but we did get
to see some cool sequences I mean my
favorite part of the whole thing was
Hodor with bran yeah yeah controlling
Hodor because they had foreshadow of
this in previous episodes him
controlling animals and him control the
whole door that one time yeah so I was
very satisfying to see him pick up the
Roose Bolton's like Weasley double aging
guy Rigas mag bring up just
snap his neck I thought the poor hodor
lose his bloody heads like he doesn't
want to kill anybody's a gentle jack
for a [ __ ] but I mean he did what he
had to do I mean and you talking about
this I this some of this stuff was a
little bit silly yeah I mean I shouldn't
say seelix I know it's gonna be
important the story at some point but
just seeing that whole vision of like
three we're all leading you like we're
just gonna be accompanying you you must
go I'm just it's too much like - lord of
the Ritz like - Lord of the Rings II
it's like it's too much like the one
ring I'm like okay like we don't need
all that [ __ ] I know it's part of the
story but in that in this episode it
almost felt out of place I think in the
thing with bran like I like the
characters playing they're fine but it's
just every time they bring all that
stuff in it just seems to disrupt the
flow of everything else
yeah but then also the thing is remember
I talked about how with brand storyline
even though I'm not as interested and
then it was combining with Jon Snow
storyline and therefore I was much more
interesting well now it looks like it's
gonna split off yeah yeah so so much for
that right yeah they're not gonna see
each other because Jon would prevent him
from going up to the north and seeing
the three-eyed Raven another cool
sequence we had was Jon Snow fighting
the guy from Pacific Rim living room I
think the head of the mutiny yeah he's a
really good actor I wonder I mean I
guess he's really serve much of Susan
about that characters I'm trying to
figure out what this whole story serves
as a purpose for like I guess I want to
see the payoff of this like the women
just end up staying they burn the play
like his brothers mother down burn the
place down the guys are all looking on
like you know and then I'm curious to
see what the payoff of this besides bran
going up north like what does this mean
for Jon Snow I'll be curious to see how
they tell that story is a season perhaps
maybe he you know by the remaining
people who are left but see his
leadership qualities yeah did a good job
you know he did end up killing that one
guy with the help of the the girls -
yeah yeah but that was a cool fight
sequence and how he died with the
scenario right and so hopefully that
that helps out John in the future but
yeah I know we do we don't we don't know
where that where that's going right yeah
something to do with the White Walkers
eventually yeah yeah something I mean
they're always keeping on I see
you know the wolf that the dire wolves
get set free it was always nice to see
them locked up you know so that was nice
but I mean it was a lose a good episode
I guess I could call this kind of a
simple episode there wasn't too much
like some of our episodes like there's
always a lot going on but this one was I
don't know it's both a little tighter
yeah the Millau last weeks had the least
amount of like locations I'm sure
broader we didn't see Tyrion which is
very rare very rare we didn't see Tyrion
at all right yeah you know we still
haven't really gotten into the whole
reek slash yeah looks like for the
preview we might get some that next yeah
same with Stannis it looks like we're
gonna get ya know miss Andre know that
yeah but I thought it was episode yeah
we got to see finally I think we finally
got to see some bad guys die in horrific
ways the bad guy we saw Joffrey died
earlier this season which was you know
satisfying but I you know we all wish
that it was worse right yeah and then we
got to see these you know these other
guys you know get what was coming to
them yeah it was it was solid obvious I
guess it wasn't one of my favorite
episodes of the season you know I love
Michelle Maclaren I should a good job
directing I just it was a good episode
again whenever when I say this isn't my
favorite episode I would say a good an
hour of Game of Thrones even if it's a
bad hour of game with Thrones is still a
damn good hour of television so when I
say it's not one of my favorite episodes
I didn't like it as much it's still good
TV I still enjoyed watched and I can't
wait for them there's no bad hour of
Game of Thrones well there might be like
little sequence lesser than yeah right
yeah that aren't that great but I've
never seen a whole episode where I'm
like oh that was a bad no no no no no no
very minor stuff yeah and I actually
think this was all my favorite ones it's
all season so far
so I'm very happy with it I think things
are gonna start picking up from from oh
definitely yeah yeah it should be good
alright guys so that's what we thought
of this episode of Game of Thrones you
can post your comments below the website
can CARICOM or on our YouTube channel
think AeroPro make sure to subscribe to
that also can find us on twitter or at
think here oh I am at Griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think your old fans
make sure you like that page and share
our videos on Twitter Facebook and all
their social media
you